نحن في انتظار بدء هذا المؤتمر
نحن ننتظر الانتخابات رياضيا
المحددة للجولة الثانية
انتخاب رئيس الجمهورية
رياضيا تم بالفعل تعريف ذلك
سيكون هنالك
[موسيقى]
لدى البعض 30 يومًا أخرى
أعرف والدي وأنا أحب الحملة
أحب الذهاب إلى الشارع وأحب صنع الطعام
أحببت الشاحنة ، كما تعلم ، أحب الجدال معها
المجتمع البرازيلي
الرغبة في التغيير
هناك بعض التغييرات التي يمكن أن تأتي
أسوأ وحاولنا خلال الحملة
تبين أن الجانب الآخر يبدو أنه لا
وصلت إلى أهم طبقة من
المجتمع لذلك نحن نحلل لنذهب
نتغلب على كذبة اليوم
51٪ كانوا يتنقلون خلال الثلاثينيات وقليلًا
لذلك تغلبنا على الكذب
[موسيقى]
هؤلاء الناخبين انتخابات آمنة
التناغم السلمي مع السلام نحن
كان لدينا يوم كامل من الانتخابات
الهدوء المطلق ما لا
من الواضح أنه لم يكن هناك
المضاعفات كما هو الحال في أي دولة أخرى
الانتخابات لكننا وصلنا إلى نهاية ذلك اليوم
إنه عدل اليقين
امتثلت الانتخابية
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]